you're strong but I could snap my
fingers
and it all cease to exist
gotta say
it's pretty magical hey everybody it's
Charlie I got a lot of requests to do in
agents of shield finale video and
explain how that's gonna work with
Avengers infinity war the ending of that
movie in Avengers 4 because they just
renewed the TV show but season 6 is not
gonna premiere till after Avengers 4 and
Captain Marvel have happened so you see
what they're doing there but if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos I
will be doing more Captain Marvel videos
really soon
clerk greg is going to be in the Captain
Marvel movie as a younger version of
Coulson because that takes place during
the 90s so also explain a little bit of
that in this video because he's been
talking about the Captain Marvel movie I
think he's been shooting it for the last
month or so since he finished shooting
on shield but obviously spoiler warning
for the shield finale if you haven't
seen it yet spoiler warning for the end
of infinity war because we need to talk
about both of those things so the
biggest question that people had at the
end of the shield finale is is why
didn't any of the shield agents vanish
after the finger snap because a lot of
people were trying to chart the timeline
between the last couple of episodes of
shield and the events of infinity war
because they kept referring to Thanos as
assaults making it seem like what was
happening was happening concurrently
with the battle in Wakanda which was
actually a relatively quick affair like
I think it lasted less than a couple of
hours I think you know like the total
start to finish timeline of infinity war
is less than a day or two so while
that's happening while shield is
battling this alien organization made up
of Kree and a couple of other races in
wall Talbot is becoming graviton but his
big thing in the finale is that he wants
to find all graviton daisies able to
stop him by jacking herself up with a
centipede serum but they lose Fitz he
does die but not because of the finger
snap and they kind of pull back on a
little bit because there's a version of
him that's in outer space and stasis
waiting to wake up in the future because
of the time travel aspect of agents of
shield season 5 there were a bunch of
them that used innopolis to travel to
the future
so Fitz travel to the future to follow
them by just putting himself in stasis
and waking up 70 plus years later so
eventually they'll mess with the
timeline they'll bring that version of
Fitz back but because all the TV
renewals and cancellations just happened
people were like is it going to be
canceled is it going to be renewed they
renewed it for a 13 episode
season six now they're not confirming
that it's going to be the final season
but what they're doing is is they're
waiting till after Avengers 4 to
premiere it and I think that's largely
in service of allowing the shield
showrunners to write to the ending of
Avengers 4 I think there are so many
plot lines during Avengers 4 that the
Russos in Disney want to keep secret so
they want all the TV shows to be able to
take advantage of the really cool things
that they're gonna do in Avengers 4 but
they don't want to have to give away the
plot to every showrunner that's trying
to write to this so they're like you
know what we'll just wait till after we
do this then you can go see the movie
you can use any plot beat you can
include all the references that you want
all the jokes there's just so many
people that work on a TV show that would
have to know the actual plot of Avengers
4 if they were gonna go concurrently
that I think they just decided to you
know let's not worry about it
well premiere after it'll fix all those
problems because we talked about this
during the hundredth episode in the
actual infinity war crossover where they
sort of name-dropping Thanos like it was
pretty clear that the shield showrunners
had an idea for what was happening
during infinity war but they may not
have known everything because I think if
they had known about the finger-snap
then they would have been at least a
couple people on the street here that
would have just whisked away if you
really wanted to bend over backwards to
try and explain the continuity errors
you could say that they're finishing
this fight here with Talbot graviton in
dropping Coulson off in the actual
Tahiti with Mei right before the fingers
snap because remember the amount of time
that passed between Emma D ma and Cole
obsidian landing at the sanctum with
their spaceship and then the battle in
Wakanda in the finger-snap was probably
about a day or so maybe less than a day
it didn't seem like that much time had
passed that would mean that the last
couple of episodes of shield would have
to take place over the course of a
couple hours which kind of breaks the
timeline a little bit but that's
probably the easiest way to explain it
is is that is they're flying away one or
two of them vanish into ashes and Daisy
craps or pants and then they all get
brought back during Avengers 4 so that
by the time she'll season 6 picks up
they're all back and they're do whatever
they want to with the plot of their TV
show and they can't make references to
some of them having vanished into ashes
and then come right back remember a
couple weeks ago when Mack
just vanished into ashes and then he
came right back yeah that was that was
really messed up the Avengers what did
they do about that I guess they fixed
everything there will be some really
weird explainers on the Netflix shows
and on these shows about people
forgetting things remembering things you
could use the mind gem in the reality
gem to explain how people would not be
remembering all the craziness of
infinity war in Avengers 4 but when it
comes to the TV shows if they're not
referencing things every five minutes
you just explain it by saying that oh
when they fix things they just fixed
everyone's memories so it's not such a
big deal anymore but the Coulson
Captain Marvel crossover the really cool
thing about this is that they're still
shooting the movie we can make all the
Hawkeye jokes about him not being in
infinity war because he was busy
following Clark Gregg around in real
life making sure he didn't give any
secrets away about the Captain Marvel
movie but they haven't said anything
about tying that to shield in
present-day Clark Drake himself said
that they will tell the origins of
shield during that movie and he'll be
like a brand new green agent fresh off
the truck like oh wow I'm so happy to
have been inducted into this crazy
organization so obviously Nick Fury is
gonna be younger he'll have both of his
eyes when we first found out that he was
going to be in the movie I did a 20
years ago comparison picture and Clark
Gregg looks almost exactly the same way
he looked twenty years ago when he would
supposedly be joining shield during the
90s so it's not like they're gonna have
to use a lot of CG to make Clark Gregg
look like a younger version of himself
but the way Clark Gregg tells it is is
that during the Iron Man movie he says
this isn't his first rodeo mr. stark
the first rodeo that he is now referring
to is the events of the Captain Marvel
movie that took place during the 90s so
it sounds like [ __ ] goes down on planet
Earth during the 90s because as Captain
Marvel to go to outer space and then
that's where she is during the events of
infinity war then the pager goes off and
that brings her back to Planet Earth but
I know there's still a thousand
questions about how the events of shield
will crossover with these two Avengers
movies so just leave them in the
comments below we'll try to answer them
and then I'll address them as I start
talking about the Captain Marvel movie
there'll be more videos about that this
summer but they're still gonna be
filming it for a little while I'm really
hopeful that they released some kind of
teaser around
makaan even though Marvel isn't doing a
big haul age panel
the thing about comic-con this summer is
that just because Marvel isn't going
doesn't mean that they're not going to
drop any footage for anything I think
that they're gonna sit on Avengers for
teasers until way later this year so I'm
not expecting anything from that the
Russos just started editing Avengers 4
they're gonna be busy for a while but I
think what'll happen is is by the end of
the year we'll see the first Avengers 4
footage but they can totally drop
Captain Marvel footage because it's set
during the 90s without having to worry
about spoiling any infinity war stuff I
know there's all kinds of questions
about how they're gonna drop teasers for
the next spider-man movie because
they're also shooting that this summer
without spoiling Avengers 4 because
spider-man is supposed to be dead so how
do you market a movie with spider-man
that picks up minutes after Avengers 4
ends best way to think about it right
now is the Hulk theory of infinity war
trailers they can do anything they want
with CG so they'll probably release some
sort of Avengers 4 teaser and then a
spider-man teaser without actually
spoiling Tom Hollands status like
they'll find some weird way to magic
something up it won't look like what the
actual film is going to look like and we
can all make guesses about what's fake
and what's real that's like the new
Marvel trailer game analyze the trailer
try to see what you can find and then
also guess what's fake and what's real
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner our strong pls private message me
so I can get your contact details I'll
name a new winner when I post new Marvel
new ant-man and the wasp footage posting
next so while you wait for that click
here for my Deadpool 2 post-credit scene
video and click here for that infinity
war eternal scene
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]